confrontation point de vue ce soir entre
aurore laluque eric delannoy on va
parler économie mais aussi politique et
notamment s'arrêter sur cette aide
exceptionnelle débloqués par les pour
les agriculteurs qui ont souffert du gel
ces quinze derniers jours un fonds de
solidarité d'un milliard d'euros a été
créé une bonne nouvelle pour la fnsea
qui reconnaît même que le gouvernement a
été plutôt réactif petite question tout
de même d'où vient ce milliards d'où
viennent d'ailleurs ces milliards qui
sont débloqués depuis un an on va en
parler avec des économistes dans un
instant d'avoir les premiers éléments de
flore sauvages
après le pire épisode de gel connu en
france depuis 30 ans le gouvernement a
annoncé un fonds de solidarité
exceptionnelle d'un milliard d'euros on
estime que sur certaines parties de
notre territoire
c'est parfois à 50 70 et peut-être même
100% d'une partie des récoltes qui ont
été perdus devant la catastrophe qui a
ravagé plusieurs milliers d'hectares de
cultures le premier ministre a promis
des mesures d'urgence
le report est l'exonération des charges
sociales le dégrèvement de la taxe
foncière sur le non bâti et la
mobilisation de dispositifs déjà
existants en matière d'activité
partielle pour les arboriculteurs et les
viticulteurs durement touchés ce sont
des bonnes mesures même si cela ne va
pas résoudre toutes les difficultés
le secteur de la viticulture était déjà
à la peine avec le boycott des vins
français par les états unis et la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
on peut pas dire que ça va répondre à
tous les problèmes
je crois que dans toutes ces mesures une
évaluation financière meilleure eu aussi
une évaluation structurel qu'il faudra
mettre en place et puis et puis voir à
quoi ça correspond
on est un stade aujourd'hui où la
profession que j'interroge major
interrogé ce matin
régulièrement en cours de chiffrage
précis sur l'ampleur de la catastrophe
en attendant de connaître l'ampleur des
dégâts une aide forfaitaire basé sur la
perte de chiffre d'affaires mensuel sera
accordée sur le modèle du fonds de
solidarité mises en place dans le cadre
de la crise sanitaire
selon une première estimation de la
fnsea un tiers au moins de la production
viticole française sera perdue à cause
du gel pour les fruits les
professionnels s'attendent à une perte
de la moitié de leur production
avec nous pour ce match des idées ce
soir au rang laluque bienvenue vous êtes
économiste eurodéputés du groupe de
l'alliance progressiste des socialistes
et démocrates et vous êtes l'auteur de
reconquête au nom de l'intérêt général
eric delannoy bienvenue à vous également
de cet économiste président du cabinet
tenzing conseil tenzing qui vient de
lancer l'appel à candidatures de la
quatrième édition du prix tenzing de
l'égalité des chances si on a quelques
minutes peut-être que vous pourrez nous
en parler personne ne dira ce soir
évidemment qu'il fallait pas débloqué ce
milliard d'euros pour les agriculteurs
pour les aider évidemment dans ce
contexte mais question d'où vient ce
milliard ça a semblé si simple de le
débloquer alors qu'on entend parler de
politique d'austérité 2 milliards
impossible à débloquer dans d'autres
secteurs
comment est ce possible eric delannoy
déjà vous avez remarqué qu'il ya une
comparaison qui est en train de se faire
avec la crise sanitaire sur la manière
dont on doit gérer ces risques
climatiques qui vont être de plus en
plus fréquents et donc moi je pense que
ça fait partie intégrante du du fonds
finance jusqu'au bout en fait hein donc
actuellement objectivement laisser ce
n'est pas la difficulté à trouver les
milliards la difficulté ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué de comment de
manière pérenne on arrive à indemniser
des risques climatiques de plus en plus
important donc il ya un problème
d'assurance et de re de restructurer
l'intégralité de la couverture des
risques pour les agriculteurs ça c'est
un vrai sujet là on est sur du court
terme
objectivement on a fait la démonstration
est d'ailleurs ça sera un problème pour
la présidentielle que trouver des
milliards c'est pas compliqué donc la
dérive à être là mais pas être évidente
donc voilà enfin moi je pense plutôt à
qu'est-ce que ça ne nous dit en termes
de danser société quel est le rôle de
l'état quel est le rôle de l'europe par
rapport à par rapport aux agriculteurs
et quels sont les rôles des assureurs et
ça ça va être quelque chose de très
important et compliqué à faire l'aller
oui je crois qu'on a un vrai sujet qui
est celui qui viennent il va nous
falloir un état providence sociale
écologique
c'est à dire que là on a un sujet précis
mais on va en avoir d'autres
il ya les inondations et à l'étranger me
ça c'est quand même un sujet écologique
à la base mine de rien aussi donc cela
veut dire qu'on va avoir besoin d'un
nouveau système de protection sociale en
règle générale ça c'est un premier point
l'autre point c'est qu'on a besoin
d'avoir une vraie
stratégie au lieu de débloquer des fonds
à chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
alors j'entends bien que c'est un
phénomène global mais ça veut dire qu'il
nous faut quand même une politique
ambitieuse de transition écologique ce
que tout ça est lié quand même au
dérèglement climatique ça veut dire
qu'il faut peser dans les négociations
internationales peser au niveau européen
et c'est plutôt qu'à chaque fois
débloqué de l'argent est gérée gérer les
crises finalement et ensuite sur la
question du financement que ce que vous
sauviez tout à l'heure alléchant que
c'est très triste lambda on se donne un
peu comment c'est possible oui pis c'est
vrai que autant au début de la crise on
sentait que les vannes était ouverte
autant là on nous a dit qu'ils auraient
de l'annulation de la dette pour les
entreprises mais qui en aurait pas pour
d'autres pour les étudiants ont fait pas
de rsa jeunes etc
donc on sent quand même effectivement un
deux poids deux mesures il faut
absolument aider toutes les personnes
qui sont en difficulté en fait sans
faire de discrimination parce que
l'argent il y en a et ça veut dire aussi
qu'à un moment il faut faire une réforme
fiscale ambitieuse et là on a un
gouvernement qui est totalement à contre
temps historique c'est-à-dire qu'on voit
bien ce qui se passe aux etats-unis avec
une ambition d'avoir des plans massifs
de relance financés par une hausse des
impôts ou le grand gros le
l'administration byden siffler la fin de
la récré fiscale nous on est en train de
faire un verre sans france mine de rien
donc ça pose aussi un sujet à ce niveau
là il va nous faire leur de la cohérence
stratégie pour une transition écologique
un état social et provident a fait à
part dans providence sociale et
écologique est tous à se financer la
hausse il faut la cohérence
eric de labarre non ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce genre de propos
je le vois dans tous les programmes
présidentiels depuis trente ans que la
fracture sociale on en a parlé en 95 que
finalement rien n'a été fait en fait on
a laissé tous des rires et donc les
politiques ambitieuses c'est vachement
chouette mais dès qu'on veut toucher à
la retraite il ya tout le monde dans la
rue dès qu'on veut faire une réforme
ambitieuse
finalement toutes les oppositions d'ici
c'est pas bien moi j'en prends une seule
une seule le dédoublement des classes
souvenez-vous les débats sur des
millions des classes les syndicats
étaient contre l'opposition et des
contres se serait pas possible
trois ans après on montre que c'est une
formidable aux réformes qui est
structurelle qui est systémique donc moi
je veux bien qu'on répète qu'il faut
tout faire et relancer l'intégralité de
ce qu'il faut mais en fait c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche et on le voit
dans ce gouvernement c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche quand abah abah y donne et
aux états unis
effectivement ils ont des plans de
relance qui sont ils sont très
importants mais on parle pas de la même
chose
ils ont un taux d'imposition qui est
ridiculement bar qui d'ailleurs a été
baissée par par par par trump
alors que nous parlons jamais nous on a
un taux d'imposition et de prélèvements
obligatoires le plus élevé au monde
donc l'idée qui consisterait à augmenter
les impôts d'un pays qui fait tiquer à
des prélèvements les plus élevés au
monde me paraît juste inconcevable et
ressources qui sont ridicules par
rapport à léo besoin de co2 qu'on a je
suis désolé mais c'est pas totalement
vrai notamment sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés puisque au niveau européen en
moyenne on va avoir un impôt inférieur
si la réforme baydan passe donc c'est un
élément de langage qu'il était bon
utilisé pendant beaucoup d'années pour
justifier des réformes il est pas vrai
il est désormais plus vrai et par
ailleurs les plans les plans sociaux et
les plans d'investissements massifs aux
états unis c'est pas que la question
sociale
on a des plans d'investissement à base
de 2000 milliards on va sur des choses
excessivement précis je me relance
industrie et on fait du verre ça veut
dire qu'il ya une vraie vision de
société
et ça ça nous manque aujourd'hui dans ce
pays une vraie vision société il y peu
en train de relancer l'économie
hayden est en train de reconstruire les
états unis on aurait bien besoin de ça
en france on en reparlera un petit peu
économie tout à l'heure on va parler
politique maintenant c'est deuxième
thème de notre match ce soir ce sont les
gauches qui tente dessus
de 2022 une vingtaine de représentants
de différents mouvements se sont
rencontrés samedi on n'y a notamment
aperçu julien bayou olivier faur anne
hidalgo
benoît hamon raphaël glucksmann et bien
sûr yannick jadot puisqu'il était à
l'initiative de ce rendez vous après
trois heures d'échangés il en est
ressorti deux choses dixit yannick jadot
lui même le respect mutuels on ne
disqualifie pas les autres à gauche et
la tenue d'une nouvelle réunion fin mai
une absence notable tout de même celle
du leader de la france insoumise jean
luc mélenchon va en parler avec vous
dans un instant on va d'abord accueillir
dans ce match david guiraud bonsoir vous
êtes porte parole de la france insoumise
quel regard vous portez sur cette
réunion qui a eu lieu samedi du côté de
la france est soumise ces kerry coquerel
ils étaient 1 donc la france en ce midi
ya participé au lit quand même pas jean
luc mélenchon qui était à des milliers
de kilomètres d'ici
est ce que vous regardez cette réunion
avec un petit sourire ironique ou avec
un vrai espoir déjà sur l'absence de
jean luc mélenchon pardon mais tout le
monde savait qu'il n'était pas là à ce
moment là il avait regardé voire
internationale car députés membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères donc
voilà les organisateurs savaient qu'ils
ne seraient pas là par choix des
organisateurs maintenant c'est vrai que
si la réunion elle permet d'avancer
justement vers cette espèce de pacte de
respect mutuel ça serait une bonne chose
d surtout sur les débats publics parce
qu'effectivement il faut parler du fond
et nous insistons à la france un fruit
sur le besoin qu'a la gauche d'avoir des
mobilisations communes c'est-à-dire de
se rendre utiles aux gens
nous on n'est pas pour une grand retour
aux années hollande ou deux mois avant
l'élection présent sortirait du chapeau
un candidat sans aucune mobilisation
aujourd'hui notre intérêt et notre enjeu
à gauche celle de nous rendre utiles à
ceux qui galèrent à ceux qui galèrent à
remplir leur frigo à ceux qui galèrent à
nourrir leurs enfants aux étudiants
pardonnez moi je sais pas si vous
m'entendez bien pour être utile aux
français il faut être élu il faut la
gagner cette élection s'il n'y a pas
d'union de ces gauches pardon c'est
mathématique sont les sondages vous ne
serez pas élu pas écouté la seule
réalité mathématique aujourd'hui qu'on
observe dans les sondages parce que
c'est des sondages donc ça vaut ce que
ça vaut
la seule réalité mathématique que l'on
voit c'est que lorsque les forces de
gauche michel n'arrive même pas à rabat
à capter leur propre électorat est donc
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de constater
quoique là
gauche est sorti très affaibli du mandat
françois hollande beaucoup de gens se
sont réfugiés dans l'abstention
ils ne croient plus en la gauche parce
que on a quand même un mandat un
quinquennat françois hollande qui est à
jouer contre les intérêts des masses
populaires est donc l'enjeu qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est pas des accords
forcément d'appareils c'est de trouver
le bon lien pour faire sortir les gens
de l'abstention et je pense moi je vous
le dis que pour faire sortir les gens de
l'abstention il faut qu'on se rende
utile la gauche moi je le répète je l'
ai déjà dit il ya quelques temps je
trouve que la fonction soumises a
souvent été seul par exemple quand il
s'agissait de défendre des gilet jaune
qu'on a traité de tous les noms d'
antisémite de tout ce que vous voulez
alors qu'en vérité c'est un mouvement de
gens qui galèrent à remplir leur frigo
quand on a été accusé d'islamophobie
schisme parce que on se battait contre
le racisme ou la détestation des
musulmans dans notre pays et compte des
discours y compris venant du
gouvernement qui met une cible sur le
dos de nos compatriotes français
musulmans
je pense que c'est là que doit être la
gauche est effectivement si on est dans
ces mobilisations communes les gens
reviendront
parce que vous savez je ne pense pas que
les gens se soient très enclin à donner
un blanc-seing aujourd'hui aux
organisations de la gauche qu'elle sous
estime cry parlement date rentrée
hollande maintenant soyons utile ça
ferait déjà bien et ça serait une bonne
avons commencé je pense donc on va
poursuivre la discussion avec nos
invités en plateau évidemment vous nous
dites si vous voulez réagir et je vous
donnerai la parole horreur laluque à la
france a soumises a été laissée un peu
seul par les autres gauche je sais pas
j'en ai rarement l'impression mais ça va
être ma vision personnelle des choses
moi je soutiens et je suis là chaque
fois qu'il ya un combat un combat qui
correspond à ma ligne politique est ce
que je défendrai ce que place publique
défend voilà tout simplement oui mais la
compliquent si j'aime à annonhcé gauche
c'est à dire que si c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui sort vainqueur de cette
union des gauches comme étant le
candidat commun vous vous soutiendrez
mais je pense que en fait je pense qu'on
met la charrue avant les boeufs là déjà
il ya un besoin de se parler et de se
parler correctement est normal et ça
peut pas se faire à mon sens même s'il
fallait absolument faire l'initiative
café café yannick jadot jassem but c'est
pas un sujet mais à un moment il faut
qu'on puisse se retrouver tous
régulièrement dans des salles pour
pouvoir travailler ensemble parler de ce
qui nous unit et on a été unie sur la
réforme des retraites
on a été unie face à l'assurance chômage
je pense que si on parle de de la
réforme du pacte de stabilité européen
son fils qu'elle en sera fini on aura à
la rigueur des nuances mais on sera mais
vous aussi qu'on parle des sujets qui
fâchent qui clivent les questions
géopolitiques les questions européennes
et c'est ça à mon sens ça ne se fait pas
dans des réunions grand public
ça ça se fait dans des réunions où
travaillent le font tous ensemble plutôt
en off est exactement comme des common
et caméras à quoi l'on à des caméras
mais exactement comme des oreilles
réunion de négociation géopolitiques ou
de négociation syndical tout simplement
entre partenaires sociaux c'est souvent
comme ça que ça se passe et c'est à mon
avis de ça dont on a besoin
d'abord le fin d'abord le fond d'abord
le fond d'accord mais les français
voteront pour une personne sans nier qu
effectivement la cinquième république
elle est ce qu'elle est et ça veut dire
que c'est l'incarnation salohy dire que
c'est une capacité à faire dd on le voit
et c'est bien et cetera mais travaillons
tranquillement sereinement le fond et
essayons d'être courtois à l'extérieur
de la noire non je sais ça m'amuse cette
réunion fait un concours de stars et à
la fin il n'en restera qu'un donc cesser
le fond le nom mais le fond regardez les
réseaux sociaux je me méfie toujours de
ski a raconté dessus mais ce qui est
amusant c'est de voir le les comptes
rendus qui sont faits eux mêmes de la
france insoumise sur les sur les comptes
rendus qui sont faits des autres si vous
voulez par exemple ou en gros finalement
personne n'est même d'accord sur ce
qu'il faut retenir de cette réunion là
donc si l'ambition c'est de réussir à se
parler correctement enfin j'espère qu'on
est dans un pays civilisé où il n'y a
pas besoin de se réunir pour pouvoir se
parler correctement
maintenant ce qui réunit essentiellement
ces gens là parce que je dis c'est gens
là c'est un spectre incroyablement large
c'est le maquereau bashing effectivement
ils ont été contre tous car il essayait
de mettre en place les manuels mâcon
mais jamais avec les mêmes arguments et
quand on voit qu'ils essaient proposé
d'aider des idées que ce soit sur les
problématiques de liessies de la laïcité
j'ai entendu comme d'habitude des choses
aberrantes sur sur la soi-disant
s'assure musulmans qui est juste un
point insupportable d'entendre ce genre
de chose enfin franchement c'est des
amalgames entretenus pour continuer à
susciter le malheur je peux pas imaginer
une division de la gauche modérée
républicaine dans lesquels je n'ai pas
la france a soumises puisse puisse
accorder sur un propos comme celui là et
là on est sur des gestions des déchets
des sujets de fond qui tient à la vision
de la société
alors david guiraud je crois que vous
voulez
et ensuite horreur laluque oui non mais
je suis heureux de voir que mois
emmanuel macron instructeur autour du
plateau
il leur fallait bien mais vous savez moi
j'ai pas de j'ai pas trop de problèmes
avec aurore laluque ou avec des jantes
génération comme thomas porte qu'on
retrouve souvent dans les dents d'autant
de combat commun dans nos luttes
communes mais la situation est exigeante
et moi c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup de
débats à mener aujourd'hui mais il
n'était pas moi je pense de manière
publique parce que c'est intéressant sur
la dette par exemple comment on gère la
dette ça c'est intéressant vous avez un
horrible libéral en plateau bah lui il
va dire c'est horrible saussez fait
horreur l'idéal voilà mais surtout ne
connaissait rien voilà en fait écoutez
je vous ai entendu 50 secondes et j'ai
l'impression d'entendre toujours les
mêmes discours de la part de gens comme
vous monsieur je vous le dis honnêtement
et mais c'est justement ce genre de
discours qu'il faut qu'il faut combattre
à mon avis tristesse qu'on fait de la
dette quand j'entends des gens dire que
il faut pas faire de relance économique
il ya trop d'état un comme si on avait
un surplus en ce moment d'infirmiers de
soignants ou professeurs des gens qui
par ailleurs risquent leur leur santé
pour que nos gamins ou que nous anciens
y vient et ben voila moi je pense que ce
débat il doit sauver là comment on fait
par exemple pour que l'état soit
restaurée il s'agit pas que de police
même si on l'a il s'agit de professeurs
il s'agit de gens dans la santé de
chercheurs et de chercheuse vous savez
il ya des lois en ce moment il ya une
loi par exemple la loi de programmation
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et bien joué dans toutes les
réactions qu'il ya eu aux lois c'est
vrai madame la vue qu'à raison il ya eu
des combats dans lesquels on s'est
retrouvés mais il ya quelque chose qui
me gène moi c'est que la gauche n'a pas
réussi en tout cas les organisations de
gauche ont très peu réussi à se mettre
autour d'une table et à impulser des
mobilisations et c'est ce qui faisait la
force de nos organisations fut il ya
quelques années
et là il ya un enjeu c est ce qu on se
retrouve par exemple sur la question de
l'assurance chômage
parce que le gouvernement s'apprête à
abandonner fille cent mille chômeurs à
les laisser sur le bord de la route dans
une période de crise moi j'aimerais bien
savoir si c'est de leur faute hein
dernière pour vous répondre avant de
passer chez toi qui effectivement il ya
un an chez sur lesquels on se retrouve
face on va se retrouver sur beaucoup de
choses mais qui est ce lui aussi la
bataille culturelle c'est à dire qu'à un
moment la gauche a été pétrifié dans des
questions de pseudo crédibilité
notamment sur les questions économiques
et à un moment faut faire justement
l'économie sérieusement et l'économie
sérieusement c'est pas se laisser comme
ça embourbé dans un espèce de lieux
communs ça c'est un premier point
donc il faut qu'on soit ambitieux sur
ces questions-là hebeisen leproux le
deuxième point c'est que peut-être
qu'autour de la table de cette réunion
il manquait aussi peut-être certains
types début moi je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de maires socialistes écolo et
c'est qu'ils font qui font qu'ils sont
dans l'action qu'ils sont à l'action
alors évidemment il y avait un vide
algoé stars y avait des mères mais il ya
quand même toute une nouvelle génération
et je trouve que ça manquait je pense
aussi à certains élus européens mais
même à d'autres avec la faucille on sent
dans la rigole manon aubry etc
ça manquait un peu de femmes et de
femmes qui font je trouverais très
peut-être que ça aiderait un peu
d'ailleurs à passer les plats y être
construit s'est dit merci beaucoup en
tout cas david guiraud d'avoir participé
le renouvellement à ce match des idées
on va poursuivre nous revenir à
l'économie on va voir ce qui se passe à
droite
hier dans le journal du dimanche ça ne
va peut-être pas échappé guillaume
pelletier vice-président délégué dlr a
dévoilé ses propositions pour 2022
ce sont ces propositions du projet de
loi 60 mesures un calendrier et une
méthode c'est tout un programme qu'ils
détaillent en 100 jours nous reprenons
avec le maquereau nice mais dit-il et je
vois réagi eric delannoy si vous
permettez je voudrais votre éclairage
sur quelques mesures et notamment celle
ci augmentation des salaires de 20% en
supprimant toutes les cotisations
sociales se seraient financés selon lui
par un micro prélèvement de 2% sur les
transactions financières et les
paiements électroniques alors je vois
sourire malgré le masque je le vois
c'est possible ça non mais enfin je veux
dire c'est passé c'est presque laissé
limite pas sérieux en fait je dis revint
à kiffa kim at il essayé de tromper
juste quelques là je ne sais pas il ya
quelques filles en séries quand je suis
enseignant devait dire non mais vide
enfin à demain on rase gratis ont
augmenté les salaires de 20% on augmente
les fonctionnaires dans tous les sens
sur le financement et sur ce point là
c'est une micro mesures une micro taxe
qui rapporte 540 milliards c'est pas une
micro taxe c'est une réforme gigantesque
de la fiscalité 540 milliards
c'est à dire un peu plus de deux fois
plus de tout ce que rapporte la tva
c'est à dire neuf fois plus que ce que
rapporte l'impôt sur le revenu c'est à
dire dix fois plus que ce que rapporte
l'impôt sur les sociétés donc c'est
vraiment une micro taxe en fait et quand
on regarde l'assiette sur laquelle il
veut asseoir sa moi personnellement je
la comprends pas alors peut-être que je
j'ai des référentiels qui vont pas bien
mais le nombre de paiements de cartes
bleues en france les paiements
électroniques
c'est de l'ordre de 600 milliards
d'euros en france 2 % de 600 milliards
ça fait 12 milliards on n'est pas au 540
milliards donc si on prend l'assiette
pour obtenir 540 milliards en prenant
que deux pour cent il faudrait 22000 à
médias que le vice président délégué des
élèves qui l'a pas fait d'économies
depuis très longtemps en fait mais c'est
donc c'est juste c'est limite grotesque
et c'est presque gênant pour lui en fait
alors dont la non et moi aussi je
pensais qu'ils avaient déco qui en fait
est tout à fait alors déjà c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas de caen lille ensemble des
propositions n'y a pas de structuration
sa part un petit peu dans tous les sens
on voit que c'est une sorte de
melting-pot d'un catalogue mesures un
peu populiste disons mais que j'étais
complètement populiste donc
effectivement mais qui n'ont pas de
colonne vertébrale c'est à dire que quel
est son projet économique pour la france
comment il fait pour relancer
l'investissement
quelle est sa vision la politique
monétaire de la politique budgétaire
quid de l'europe la banque centrale
européenne fin s'il veut faire vraiment
de l'économie qu'il y avait quoi là on
est sur quelque chose effectivement
c'est un peu du grand du grand n'importe
quoi et par ailleurs juste un point sur
sa proposition phare qui est donc une
augmentation des salaires sans
cotisation faut se rendre compte que les
cotisations sociales en connais mal
notre système de protection sociale dans
ce pays et c'est bien dommage c'est du
salaire différé c'est pas l'état qui va
prendre cet argent et qui va l'utiliser
c'est du salaire différé c'est votre
argent que vous allez toucher plus tard
dans le système de retraites etc que ça
il faut il faut comme aussi faire
attention à ce genre de choses en fait
ils proposent un détricotage très très
dur par ailleurs de la sécurité sociale
la sécurité sociale tout simplement
prévoit l'appui sur les questions
fiscales moi je ne sais que dire les
bras maintenant mais je pour le coup je
souscris tout à fait à ce qui est dit je
voudrais juste rajouter un point même en
termes de colonne vertébrale sociétale
de ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
ce monsieur il en train de dire quand
bien même ce serait possible
cette taxe de 2 % qu'on va faire reposer
la solidarité et les quotidiens et
l'assaut la veille sécurité sociale sur
la consommation sur la finance enfin je
dire c'est quand même incroyable faillir
on est on marche sur la tête quoi donc
donc pour moi c'est je pense qu'il faut
faire j'espère qu'il ne sera pas
soutenue même s'il valérie pécresse en
d'autres temps assorti aussi beaucoup
d'âneries
oui c'est vraiment pas une question
politique c'est un question paraît de
des idéologies disons là on est vraiment
sur un mot sur un complice de sérieux de
sérieux total et franchement ce serait
bien qu'on ait des débats on est pas
d'accord mais on est complètement
sérieux et l'ariège où les lie les deux
économistes sur ce point parce que
c'était quand même une interview qui a
beaucoup fait parler hier et qui
interpellait en tant que français qui
n'y connait rien qui se disait à chaque
encore la rupture ça plaît mais ça veut
pas dire que c'est forcément tôt nabeul
mais ça veut dire qu'on part quand il ya
un vrai sujet qui est celui du pouvoir
d'achat et celui des salaires etc
augmentent et les minima sociaux dans
une période où on a une crise sociale et
on a besoin de faire en sorte que tout
le monde aille bien socialement ne
serait ce que pour que l'économie
reprenne ça par contre c'est un vrai
sujet elle est quatrième thème de ce
match le lancement des états généraux de
la laïcité là aussi c'était dans le jdd
par marlène schiappa d'ailleurs ça
commence demain ça va aller très vite
avec des religieux des intellectuels des
associations des syndicats des jeunes
ont envahi par les libertés d'expression
intégration l'initiative ne séduit pas
tout le monde évidemment et soulève même
un peu d'incompréhension notamment chez
le communiste et ian brossât qu'était
sur public sénat ce matin sort d'une loi
soit le séparatisme et maintenant
marlène schiappa nous sort les états
généraux de la laïcité non mais
sérieusement je sais bien que marlène
schiappa un ministère croupion et
qu'elle est obligée tous les matins de
créer le buzz médiatique pour faire
croire qu'elle travaille enfin en
l'occurrence ça n'a aucun sens et à la
loi de 1905 appliquons la loi de 1905
on n'a pas besoin tous les jours de
remettre une pièce dans la machine sur
le sujet alors c'est un peu violent sur
la forme c'est vrai sur le fond est ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'états généraux
de la laïcité et vous répondre aussi sur
la forme un nom mais sur la fin on va se
dire c'est pas c'est pas très grave on
est habitué c'est cette forme un peu
ridicule de gens qui n'ont rien à dire
mais ce qui est ce qui est un peu
embêtant c'est que non ce qui est
vraiment très embêtant c'est que ian
brossât n'a pas compris ce que voulait
faire marc les chats pas ou n'a pas
voulu comprendre ce que voulait faire
pour ces gens là j'ai l'impression que
c'est soit répressif soit le mois soit
rien en fait
à quoi va répondre ces états généraux
ils vont répondre à un besoin de
pédagogie de formation et de prise de
température sur une jeunesse qui
aujourd'hui est totalement déboussolée
mais on n'a pas forcément de résultats
politiques à attendre de ce rendez vous
et ont les bons points de vue si je
m'inscris dans cette dans ces états
généraux c'est pour mettre en évidence
un promu premier type de société qui est
un vrai sujet qui s'il est laissé à
l'extrême droite ou à l'extrême-gauche
london dans les deux cas ce sera une
catastrophe ne donnera rien donc l'idée
c'est effectivement de ne pas compléter
la loi sur le séparatisme de ses pédalos
sûr que la partie ça n'a rien à voir
avec ça ou pas grand chose à voir avec
ça c'était pour protéger la france
n'atteint certes d'une certaine dérive
en l'occurrence de l'islamisme et ça n'a
rien à voir l'islam
rappelons le là on est en train de se
dire il ya une jeunesse qui un peu à la
dérive dans l'appréciation qu'elle a de
ce qu'est la laïcité de ce qu'est la
liberté d'expression les derniers
sondages qui le montrer c'est juste
dramatique et donc il faut revenir
expliqué il faut voir comment
quelles sont les idées des intérêts
qu'il faut prendre du recul quelles sont
les idées des intellectuels de tous
bords sur c'est quoi faire laïcité en
france
comment on peut prendre ce recul et
quelles sont les actions qu'on peut
mettre en place en termes de formation
et pédagogie et sortir du tout répressif
qui est aujourd'hui pris en charge par
la loi c'est ça les états généraux
alors après on peut gloser sur est ce
que c'est le moment pas le moment on met
sans perspective politique non mais oui
mais dans ces cas là on fait si on fait
jamais rien quoi
en fait j'ai sur la question de la forme
j'étais d'accord ce que la forme de ian
brossât a été violente
mais dire qu'il n'a pas de fond c'est
aussi très violent il en a quand même un
largement est la moins démontré a plu à
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises il a même
pas besoin de le démontrer d'ailleurs
donc vous avez juste pour dire sur la
question de la forme faisons tous
peut-être un petit peu un petit peu
attention
non moi je suis d'accord avec avec yann
il ya une loi 1905 parfaite loi de
compromis lois de protection qui est je
n'arrive pas à comprendre
j'ai absolument pas à comprendre du
moins j'ai peur de comprendre même le
ronde et pédagogiques dont on parle mais
il a bouté dago j on peut le faire bien
différemment qu'en faisant des états
généraux en fait et comment on pouvait
le faire à travers un observatoire qui
était dédiée à sa et qui était très bon
et bien il y avait il ya des professeurs
qui peuvent se marier qui peuvent le
faire mais ça c'est votre point de vue
bien aussi c'est que ça marche pas il ya
il ya moi j'ai vu de très bons résultats
au contraire de l'observatoire de la
laïcité après tout ça ça prend du temps
et après aussi a beaucoup de choses à
déconstruire parce qu'on entend tout et
n'importe quoi sur la question là de la
laïcité on entend certains interdits qui
n'existent pas par exemple
moi j'ai justement pas l'impression que
la jeunesse ne comprend pas à la laïcité
je rencontrerai la comprend bien et
qu'elle a envie de l'appliquer pour de
vrai et que ça pose ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes par ailleurs moi je
vais vous dire on parlait tout à l'heure
des manuels la crau et vous ne disiez la
gauche n'a qu'une seule chaussée
lentilles macro nisme mois s'il y avait
quelque chose sur lequel je faisais
confiance à emmanuel macron c'était pour
être un libéral politique et le discours
qu'il avait pendant la campagne
présidentielle n'était pas du tout celui
qui l'a notamment sur la question de la
laïcité et je le dis à mon pain avec pas
pour faire de la punchline du débat
enfin je le dis avec regret et grande
inquiétude parce que je trouve que ce
qu'on a
train de faire aujourd'hui est très très
très inquiétant
on est en train d'alimenter certain
sentiment qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'alimenter aujourd'hui surtout pas donc
voilà ça c'est mon point de vue je ne
comprends pas ces états généraux ou du
moins j'ai une peur de les comprendre
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on a des
gamins qui font la queue pour pouvoir
manger manger dans la capitale de france
et c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il
faudrait faire des états généraux non
mais mon de choses qui sait peut-être
sur la question du logement
bah ils sont toujours en argot en droit
de réclamer à manger malheureusement les
situations sont malheureusement les
situations je ne sens dramatique bayadh
et un joli la solution il ya des
magnifiques slogans se devrait allez
dire ça aux gamins qui sont en train de
faire avec vous non mais je sais bien
oui mais c'est une réalité
évidemment les élites et bien une crise
cette crise en les noms qu'on essayait
de la gérer c'est pas facile
au lieu des 9,1 euros je peux pas
laisser dire ça c'est pas possible
hollywood et vernement dans cette crise
a fait plus que n'importe qui dans le
monde entier pour soutenir les
entreprises les salariés et les jeunes
au point qu'aujourd'hui sur les moins de
30 ans il ya une une un plébiscite de ce
qui est en train d'enfler donc faut
arrêter aussi la part belle à un dire
n'importe quoi
samuel 1 h non on s'en sort pas si nous
la crise a besoin d'autre chose que des
petites polémiques ridicules qui ne
regarde pas ce qui a été fait regardez
ce qui a été fait dans le détail et vous
verrez que ce que vous dites est faux
c'est factuellement faux maintenant sur
les états généraux et ce matin je n'ai
jamais inquiet temps de réfléchir
pardon mais ça n'est jamais inquiétant
de réfléchir si ça vous inquiète vous
moi je ne m'inquiète pas parce que ça
permet de prendre du recul ce que le
politique ne fait jamais donc au moins
il ya celle ci doit vous connaissez ne
fait jamais main
des mamelons jalma citée de le frère
c'est un premier - le deuxième point
écouté quand je vois un intellectuel
comme patrick weil dire que tout ça
c'est une opération de com
excusez moi mais la prise de recul et la
réflexion ça me paraît bien je donne
qu'aux vives ont participé par koenig
barbara cassin richard malka
ça fait pas beaucoup de diversité
intellectuelle tout ça me semble enfin
je vous amène sur cette question c'est à
ça c'est un point donc on voit bien là
l'opération de com ensuite sur la
gestion de la crise
vous pouvez me couper la parole vous
pouvez parler plus fort que moi et le
répéter il le répétait de dire qu'on a
été le meilleur pays qu'on était celui
qui a fait le maximum et c'était pas de
questions meilleur de sa basse est ce
que vous êtes c'est également à margut
je suis un peu le moment dire qu'on
était les moins seyant scène au monde
doit être relativement un bloc même
qu'on a très très bien géré la crise
voilà on donne deux secondes la dirigent
vers les économique et social à gérer
non mais c'est pas pour ce qui concerne
la licité encore une fois je pense que
quelles que soient les profils des
personnes qui sont ni va pas y avoir
seulement les réflexions des
intellectuels ils vont poser des bases
ils vont perdre un cadrage pour faire
ensuite faire une grande enquête auprès
cinquante mille jeunes c'est quand même
intéressant de savoir ce que ces jeunes
la honte à dire par rapport au premier
sondage qui ont été faits et qui eux
sont très inquiétants parce que quand on
parle que 52% des jeunes aujourd'hui ne
souhaite pas qu'on regarde les sk a
porté les lumières à savoir la la
capacité à pouvoir critiquer les
religions remettent en cause la laïcité
avec une remise à plat il et ça n'est
rien d'autre que ça et les lois sur la
loi de 1905 par bon c'est une loi qui
est très bien faite sur le qu'il faut
rappeler effectivement mais qui ne
suffit pas parce que ce ne sont pas des
se sont pas des outils qui permettent
d'aller faire de la pédagogie et de la
formation c'était là tout cette loi il
suffit de l'utiliser et par ailleurs la
cfdt ne participe pas à ces états
généraux et l'échangé passionnant merci
à tous les deux fait d'y avoir participé
merci pour ce match des idées c'est donc
la fin de cette émission se retrouvent
demain 18h à 22h30
demain matin bonjour chez vous dès 7h30
au rayonnement de finir recevra frédéric
péchenard vice-président et l'air de la
région ile de france en charge de la
sécurité excellente soirée sur public
sénat
[Musique]